an absolutely stunning scheme has been
uncovered to falsely accuse wait for it
special prosecutor Robert Muller of
sexual assault in order to do what
discredit the Trump Russia
investigations maybe try to push the
midterms towards Republicans which now
are just six days away we talk about
projection from the Trump administration
on the program often and there's
projection and then there's projections
so let's go through some examples Obama
is terrible on the debt and deficit the
reality is Republicans don't really care
about the debt and deficit and Trump has
blown it up just like george w bush tit
another example fake news slamming the
Trump administration is a huge problem
in reality it's the Trump administration
that are actually the purveyors of the
fake news not the victims of it one more
example before I get to this one voter
fraud and voter impersonation are huge
problems reality they're very rare but
those most frequently arrested for voter
impersonation voter fraud trying to vote
twice are people on the right who are
trying to prove a point about how easy
it is to commit the fraud turns out it's
not so easy because they've gotten
caught many times now and then we get to
the ultimate projection which is about
false sexual assault allegations the
right insists and I've interviewed some
of them that the real problem around
sexual assault is not victims opting not
to come forward because of stigma and
fear it is not the epidemic that some
claim exists when it comes to domestic
violence and sexual violence but they
claim that the real problem is there are
simply too many fake rape and sexual
assault allegations and that it's too
easy to get people in trouble and here
they are caught
planning false sexual assault
allegations against robert muller and
they got caught originally independent
journalist scott's dead
wrote in The Guardian that a smear
campaign was imminent and he tweeted
about it yesterday saying I wasn't going
to report on this but I think my fears
are coming true based on information
that I am privy to
I believe false accusations will be
spread about Muller in order to
discredit him and possibly the
journalists who are preparing this story
the Atlantic is reporting that a company
run by approached from conspiracy
theorists has been offering to pay women
to make false sexual assault allegations
against Robert Muller the Muller team is
aware of it a spokesman for Muller says
that they've referred this scam to the
FBI for further investigation several
journalists were contacted by a woman
claiming to be called Lorraine Parsons
as well as one named Jennifer Taub they
both had pretty similar stories which
were that a man claiming to work for
surefire insurance
hired by Republican activist Jack
Burkman offered them about $20,000 to
make accusations against Robert Muller
of sexual harassment workplace
harassment sexual misconduct now are
these even women who are connected to
Robert Muller well it's not totally
clear at least with one of them Parsons
claimed that she worked for Muller 44
years ago and barely saw him at a law
firm but the law firm that was cited
says we have no record of this woman
ever working for us the man she spoke to
allegedly offered to pay off her credit
card debt and give her 20 grand then
Jennifer Taub is the other woman who was
contacted similar offers were made and
this guy Berkman was a big pusher of
that Seth Rich DNC murder conspiracy
theory as well not surprisingly that
he's running in this circles in these
circles and I you know Pat there's
another element to this which I kind of
hesitate to even get into which is that
there's this Republican kid named Jacob
Wall who is like very popular on Twitter
and Trump often retweets him and it
appears that there's a connection
between him and this story he was pre
promoting the story yesterday the day
before yesterday I
believe and it turns out that the
registration of this company surefire
insurance is connected to Jacob walls
mom and I you know I don't even know if
we we should or need to get into that
but like this stinks at every level yeah
I'm not even familiar with this person
but it certainly does think at every
level and I'm just thinking even if
these allegations were true and there
were actual sexual assault allegations
made against Muller that wouldn't that
wouldn't end the investigation certainly
he would have to step down I think but
someone would replace him it's not like
every allegation made against Trump and
potential collusion between Trump and
Russia would go out the window because
Muller went down over some reason like
this yeah that's a fair point like Trump
was on tape talking about grab him by
the [ __ ] you can just do it when you're
famous you don't even have to ask and he
was elected president like even if there
was a credible allegation against Robert
Mulder from 44 years ago does it
actually even relate to his credibility
running this investigation this
investigation doesn't even have to do
really with sexual assault although
Donald Trump has it has to do with
someone who has been accused by dozens
of women or more than a dozen women the
bad news though is that there are people
on the right who think that the story is
Muller has been accused of sexual
assault
even though really the story is that
people have been caught offering to pay
money to women to make fake allegations
against Robert Muller there are people
and I've seen some of the discussions
online who think that Muller has
actually been accused and you've got the
misreporting combined with the confusion
combined with the ignorance that is sort
of the baseline of politics on the right
in the United States right now and you
still end up with a story that's going
to have to be discredited and like with
voter fraud they are the source of the
false rape allegations and they got
caught and we'll see what the follow-up
is